hey youtubers is Charlie so a lot of you
guys had extra questions about the
explanation for zoom hunter zolomon on
the flash season 2 so this video is
going to explain that stuff just careful
for spoilers through episode 18 on the
flash if you haven't seen it yet so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to start
with the story that they gave us in the
episode then I'll explain some of the
twists so here we go what they explained
is that as a child hunter zolomon was
forced to watch his father kill his
mother his father was sent to prison he
was sent to the American Horror Story
orphanage grew up to be a serial killer
was convicted of 23 murders with his ZZ
Top Charles Manson beard there was
thrown into an institution and actually
the name of the institution is an easter
egg
it's the Perez Institute George Perez
was a longtime DC artist he was actually
the one that did the artwork for crisis
on Infinite Earths Infinite Crisis whole
bunch other DC titles but while he was
in there they were giving an
electroshock amid one of those sessions
the earth 2 particle accelerator
exploded he was it with a Dark Matter
wave and got speed force powers just
like Barry as a deranged person with
speed force powers he became the zoom
character but didn't get the name zoom
until that story that Harrison wells
told a couple episodes ago where he said
that he got a bunch of cops in the house
killed them all but let one survive then
once that cop explained that all he saw
was lightning zooming all around that's
how he got the name zoom his name was
never Jay Garrick so that's actually a
question that we're gonna have to come
back to in a second but ever since then
he started using velocity 9 to try and
get even faster try and get even
stronger and that's where he ran into
problems where it started degrading his
cells so that's when he got the
brilliant idea to go back in time get a
previous version of himself just to mess
with people so this is the previous
version of himself before he started
taking velocity 9 that's why his
lightning is still the same color as
Barry's because he hasn't got to the
point where he's as fast as his future
self with the use of velocity 9 so when
the wormhole opens he sends the previous
version of himself through to become the
Jay Garrick persona and insert himself
with team flash in the rest is history
the rest we've seen all play out on
screen learn to find a cure but really
come in time to find that the only thing
that will heal him is the Speed Force
naturally taken from the cells of
another speedster like Barry so let's
just answer the biggest question first
if
boom killed the previous version of
himself why is he still alive why wasn't
he erased from the timeline well he
calls it a time remnant it's the same
logic that explains how the
reverse-flash came back this season but
from before he became Harrison wells
well what the writers are doing is
they're using the Speed Force to kind of
bend the traditional ideas about how
space-time works on TV shows so they
haven't really explained the logic
behind time remnants that well but maybe
they did and it just hit the cutting
room floor for this version of hunter
zolomon that he killed from early on the
timeline was just a copy it wasn't the
original I know it totally doesn't make
sense you can totally yell at them at
comic-con or if they ever do a Q&A can
be like could you please explain this
but here's the other big thing this is
one of the funniest things that I saw on
Twitter the other day after the episode
aired Mark Waid one of the biggest flash
comic writers of all time was really
pissed off at what they had done with
the Jay Garrick character what he was
mad about is that he thought the TV show
was saying that Jay Garrick had never
been a hero he was always a murderer but
here's where it gets really exciting
greg berlanti who's you know kind of in
charge of everything he's like the
captain of the ship said that don't
worry we would never do that to a
beloved character like Jay Garrick and
this is what I think he meant is that
all the versions of this person here the
one who we know is zoom in hunter
zolomon they're all hunter zolomon one
of them was just pretending to be Jay
Garrick so what does that mean well the
exciting thing now is that there is a
version of Jay Garrick somewhere out
there that they're keeping in their back
pocket it could be the man in the metal
mask which I'm actually kind of hoping
it is it could be someone else so if
they're going to make us wait till the
very last episode to find out who's
underneath that mask that that's kind of
why I think it's Jay Garrick because
it's going to be like here's that
awesome comic book character that you've
loved for so long look he wasn't a
villain we weren't dragging him through
the mud the whole time in the comics
hunter zolomon does become the zoom
character but the way it happens the
backstory it's all very different so
even though the TV shows change that
they've kept the name the same like
hunters olam on all the versions of
hunter zolomon have always become zoom
this one just happens to be pretending
to be Jay Garrick so now the real
question is is how are they going to
surface Jay Garrick is the man in the
metal mask going to be an
the future version of this character
here is it going to be a completely
different actor because there are only a
couple ways that they could surface jay
garrick now it all depends on where the
name Jay Garrick came from that's what
the show has not explained yet who is
Jay Garrick in how did hunter zolomon
get his name
did he just invent the name or did he
borrow the name from another person they
just they haven't explained that yet so
let me know in the comments who do you
think the real Jay Garrick is is that
another version of this Teddy Sears
actor here or is it going to be a
completely different actor giveaway time
though if you guys didn't know there is
a new round of the flash giveaway I mean
it's really it's a DC giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video I'm
going to be doing a flash trailer video
for the next episode in a couple days
I'll announce the winner when I post
that if you guys didn't see it I just
did a big video for Ironman in the new
spider-man movie they just confirmed
that Robert Downey jr. is going to be in
that new spider-man movie you can click
here to learn all about it there's all
kinds of funny aunt made Tony Stark's
stuff going on now and you can click
here for my big flash video from earlier
this week thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight